en décembre 2015 195 états s'engagent à
limiter le réchauffement climatique en
dessous de deux degrés un seuil qui
entraînerait des conséquences graves
mais la planète on est déjà touché le
changement climatique il est en route
la vigne est déjà alerté depuis très
longtemps le maïs on le sait mais de
plus en plus tôt et on a gagné un mois
deux dates de semis au cours des trente
dernières années donc dans le monde
agricole
il ya déjà les agriculteurs se ferment
les yeux mais ça existe déjà
hier soir une conférence sur le sujet
s'est tenue à l'eau vs qu l'observatoire
versailles saint quentin une première
étape pour comprendre avant tout le
changement climatique connaître les
impacts de nos comportements et comment
s'adapter je crois qu'il est important
justement de ne pas de ne pas être
anxiogène c'est à dire que ce qu'il faut
c'est c'est que tout un chacun se mette
en mouvement
mais l'anxiété n'a jamais permis de
mettre en mouvement il faut il faut que
les gens se rendent compte que qui a
certes un problème est que c'est un
problème pour lesquelles on a des
solutions pour lesquelles ces de ces
solutions sont pas nécessairement
coûteuse et on doit essayer aussi de
rechercher des solutions qui sont pas
trop coûteuse des solutions qui amène
d'autres bénéfices du particulier à la
collectivité territoriale tout le monde
est concerné pour que la planète
commence à guérir